HAIR'S LOOKING AT YOU, KID.
IF THERE'S ONE THING THE
INTERNET HAS TAUGHT ME IS MY
CURRENT HAIRCUT IS THE WORST
THING TO HAPPEN ON
TELEVISION SINCE THE "LOST"
FINALE.
WELL, THE REST OF MY
HAIR IS IN PURGATORY, THAT'S
WHAT IT IS.
PEOPLE KEEP ASKING ME,
"WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?"
AND I WAS LIKE, "I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S HAIR. IT GROWS BACK. WHO
GIVES A [BLEEP]."
BUT COMEDIANS I WILL SHOW
YOU TRULY HORRIFYING
HAIRCUTS FROM THE SUBREDDIT,
JUST [BLEEP] MY [BLEEP] UP,
AND I WANT TO YOU TELL ME
WHAT THEY TOLD THE BARBER TO
DO.
I WILL START THE CLOCK NOW.
FIRST ONE.
>> CRAIG FERGUSON.
>> MAKE ME LOOK LIKE I'M
JUST BEING BORN.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
SETH.
>> MAKE ME LOOK LIKE BURNING
MAN ANDY SAMBERG.
>> Chris: GREG PROOPS.
>> YOU THINK SEA WORLD IS
CRUEL TO WHALES?
>> Chris: POINTS.
CRAIG FERGUSON.
>> I WANT TO LOOK LIKE I'M
TOO SHORT FOR MY MUSTACHE.
>> Chris: POINTS.